hello everyone and welcome to today
network activity in the b27 plus
neuronal culture system with a maestro
Pro MEA platform presented by dr. Daniel
Millard manager and application
development at accion Biosystems
I'm Cindy Valdez and I'll be your
moderator for this educational webinar
presented by lab roots and sponsored by
thermo Fisher Scientific before we begin
I'd like to remind everyone that this
event is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want at any time during
the presentation just click on that
green Q&A button located at the lower
left of your presentation window type
your questions into the box that appear
on the screen I'll answer as many
questions as we have time for at the end
of the presentation also we will be
conducting some polls during the
presentation and would appreciate your
participation the polls will pop up in
your slide window in fact please join me
in our first poll of the day how often
do you perform neural assays in vitro go
ahead now and click on the answer that
best reflects your work thanks again for
participating also please notice that
you will be viewing the presentation in
this slide window to enlarge the window
just click on the screen icon located on
the lower right if you have any trouble
seeing or hearing the presentation
please click on the support button at
the top right of the presentation window
or use the Q&A button and let us know
you're having a problem I'd now like to
introduce today's speaker dr. Daniel
Millard dr. Millard received his PhD in
biomedical engineering at the Georgia
Institute of Technology and specialized
in neural engineering as accion bio
systems his team identifies develops and
implements advanced applications for the
maestro pro and maestro edge multi well
micro electrode array platforms their
goal is to establish and refine
electrophysiological assays that are
scientifically rigorous yet also
accessible and scalable by modeling
complex human systems in vitro such as a
seizure or arrhythmia and a dish they
hope content
experts answer questions in drug
discovery safety toxicology genetics or
disease dr. Miller also serves a
leadership role on the CIPA myocyte core
team and is a co-chair of the Hesse
Newtok initiative aimed at improving in
vitro neural assays for evaluating cv
orogenic risks please join me now in
welcoming dr. Millard I will now turn
the presentation over to him welcome sir
thank you for the kind introduction as
Suzy just mentioned I am Daniel Millard
the manager for applications development
at axiom bio systems and today I'll be
discussing the maturation of neural
network activity in the b27 plus journal
culture system as measured with a
maestro Pro MEA platform
I'll start by describing a future ins
and biotechnology over the last 10 years
the first is the re-establishment of
phenotypic screening techniques which
has shown success for identifying new
first in-class drugs an emerging
application in phenotypic screening is
the development of disease and edition
models whereby human disease phenotypes
are recapitulated using in vitro
constructs via genetic or other
manipulations disease in the dish models
are further facilitated by the next
trend which is the discovery of induced
pluripotent stem cell technology the
method through which human biology such
as cardiomyocytes or neural networks can
be readily interrogated in vitro finally
industry trends have emphasized the
development of in vitro methods for the
evaluation of drug safety in the case of
CIPA and Dixon or environmental
toxicology in the case of tox 21 and
reach each of these trends supports the
need to model complex human systems in
vitro and there are a number of obvious
advances to consider for in vitro assays
compared to systems level animal studies
in vitro assays are generally much
simpler and more cost effective
however in vitro neural assays can exist
along a broad spectrum of complexity and
thus may not be suitable to answer all
questions if for instance isolated
neurons are used in vitro in vitro
neural network assays bridged the gap
between single cell neuron assays and
animal studies where mini neurons of
multiple cell types formed functional
synaptic connections allowing the in
vitro networks to reproduce aspects of
higher order neural circuit function at
the same time neural network assays can
be performed in a multi wall plate to
reduce cost and
we'll higher throughputs for example in
a single plate a number of treatment
conditions can be tested simultaneously
for applications and drug safety and
toxicology stem cell development and
optimization and the generation of
disease and addition models for each
application multiple conditions can be
tested per plate allowing scientists to
move faster from questions to answers
whether it's compounds reagents for
genotypes that we need to be optimized
in the experiment key biological
variables of interest for in vitro
assays have a direct effect on the
downstream function of the cellular
network for electroactive cells like
neurons the networked electrophysiology
defines function therefore it is
critically important to measure
electrical activity from multiple
locations within a functionally
connected cellular network micro
electrode array technology does exactly
this by providing a direct measure of
function for electroactive cells in a
multi well micro electrode array assay
there are multiple micro electrodes
embedded in the substrate of each well
those threads here by the orange circles
as neurons are deposited into each well
they settle to the bottom and attach to
the surface and after many days in
culture the neuron slowly extend axons
and develop synaptic connections to form
a functional network by sampling the
electrical activity from neighboring
neurons the signal is collected from
each electrode together provide
information on the network activity
that's providing us functional
electrophysiology readout aside from the
cells and the recording technology the
final critical component to an in-vitro
neurophysiology assay is the culture
medium neural cultures typically require
21 to 28 days to form a functional
Network in vitro and that's the culture
medium must provide a nourishing
environment during that time frame in
particular the media must support
long-term cell viability to keep the
cells alive and attached to the
substrate and must enable electrical
activity with the right Bionic man
together the viability and excitability
afforded by the media environment drives
the formation of synaptic connections
and the network activity phenotype
scientists from thermo Fisher have
demonstrated inherent cell viability for
rodent cortical neurons and their
initial characterization of the b27 plus
neuronal culture system this
presentation will assess the resulting
Network activity that follows these
improvements to the structural integrity
of the in vitro cell culture to do so we
evaluated three key features of network
activity that can be derived from
analysis of electrophysiologic spiking
activity first are the neurons even
functionally active we can answer this
question by quantifying the rate of
spontaneous action potentials detected
across the micro electrode array this
value has termed the mean firing rate
using this information we can assess how
many electrodes in a culture well detect
functional spiking activity giving an
estimate of the coverage across the
electric array the coverage is important
to ensure that we're singing from enough
neurons to be confident in assessing the
network phenotype second excitable
neurons may fire multiple action
potentials in a short period which is
called a burst they are established
there are established algorithms in the
field of neurophysiology that can detect
and quantify burst behavior once a
person is detected many features about
the burst can be used to characterise to
network activities such as the frequency
and duration of the verse or how many
spikes are in each burst on average
these features describe the burst
morphology whereas we can also compute
measures of burst organization such as
how rhythmic or regular the bursar in
time finally as synaptic functional
synaptic connections develop between
neurons in a population bursting may be
associated with synchronized activity
across the network synchrony may be used
to interpret network connectivity and is
characterized by coincidence spiking
activity across multiple electrodes in
the array
we need a way to organize Network
spiking activity across space and time
to visualize and then quantify these
features of the network phenotype namely
the functionality excitability and
connectivity that we just discussed
throughout this presentation I'll
organize the signals from the single
culture well into a raster plot if we
focus on the raw bolted signal acquired
from a single electrode indicated here
on the left we can indicate each action
potential detected by a single tick tick
mark so as an algorithm operates on this
voltage signal and detect action
potentials each of the vertical lines
below indicates the exact timing of that
action potential this series of tick
marks describes the timing of X
potentials on a single electrode and
then a raster plot stacks these tick
marks from each electrodes such as the
periods of increased activity or
coincident spiking can be readily
visualized here the tick marks labeled
in blue a burst of action potentials so
they've been detected and identified as
a burst according to Augmented
algorithms and the magenta boxes outline
areas of synchrony and network bursting
where again automated algorithms has
detected the coincidence biking across
electrodes within the wall for this
study we use the recently released
maestro probe multi-well mea platform
from axiom Biosystems
the maestro pro accepts accion and the
egg plates with 12 48 or 96 wells of
various types including our classic
plates or side of you plates the latter
of which are transparent for cell
imaging there are 768 electrodes
distributed across the wells in each
plate and all 768 electrodes are sampled
simultaneously at 12 and 1/2 kilohertz
by the maestro pro the maestro edge was
also introduced recently and accepts 24
world plates with 384 electrodes aside
from the well and electrode counts the
maestro and edge have identical features
which I'll briefly touch on now the bio
core v4 processor is the interface
between the biology and the electronics
this is responsible for all signal
acquisition by the maestro pro net the
v4 chip provides stronger signals writer
frequency content
significant flexibility as compared to
the previous iteration and the maestro
each maestro Pro has 12 cores
while the maestro Edge has 6 course the
maestro Pro and edge also includes
integrated environmental controls which
is critically important for a successful
assay as the cells are a product of
their environment a single 100 percent
co2 input is required on the back panel
and then the internal gas gas mixer of
the device delivers 5 percent co2 to the
plate chamber using a 360 degree shower
design to evenly distribute the gas
across the chamber the MEA plate itself
rests on a heater plate heating from the
bottom while the ITA coating on the
glass chamber door-- allows it to heat
the plate from above as well
finally the maestro pronouns have been
designed with a one-button setup in mind
pressing the button automatically
operates the motorized plate chamber to
securely dock to plate adjust the co2
and temperature to optimise the cell
environment and scans the plate barcode
to configure software and file handling
this is one example of how we have
designed the maestro pro edge to make
electrophysiology intuitive and
accessible and as the data is sampled by
the electronics the axis navigator
software acquires stores and processes
the data in real time here we see the
revolted signals being detected on each
of the 16 electrodes in this well on a
48 well plate SPECT detection algorithms
operate in real-time to extract the
extracellular action potentials
displayed here in a separate window in
addition the spikes are organized into a
real-time raster plot and finally the
activity map represents the spiking
activity occurring across the entire
plate in a single viewing window with
each flash of color indicating a
synchronized Network spiking event in
addition to axis navigator which
processes analyzes and saves the data
there are complimentary offline tools
that allow the user to perform
additional analyses in the neural metric
tool and that's including parameters for
customizing burst and synchrony
algorithms for detection computation
results or the axisymmetric plotting
tool which is used to compile data
across an experiment and generate
publication ready figures so now that
we've gone over the cells and platform
views for this study as well as the b27
plus a neuronal culture system and the
motivations for the study I'd like to
quickly go over some of the study
details an experimental protocol so we
used three side of you MEA 48 well
plates and these plates here were coated
with poly de-icing to generate a surface
that the cells would adhere to well the
cells in particular were the primary
rodent cortical neurons and they were
seeded at two different densities 80,000
and 100,000 cells per well within the
equal six per condition per plate those
conditions were the b27 catalog media
and the b27 plus b27 catalog with serum
and then supplier vp which is a
commercial media from another vendor
cells were maintained for 35 days in
vitro with half of media changes every
two to three days that was on a Monday
Wednesday Friday schedule the recordings
were then acquired 24 hours after the
media changes so at Tuesday Thursday
Saturday schedule and then analyzed
using accessed navigator for this all of
the data that I'll show here in the
subsequent slides we focused on the
80,000 cells per well indeed it was as
we'll see more than sufficient number of
cells and cell density in order to
characterize the activity from these
various media types and that's what
we'll do here so on the Left I'm showing
an activity map a static representation
of the activity map which is averaging
over a long period of time the activity
on each electrode within a while across
the various conditions on the plate so
again each of these conditions were
looking at as an 80,000 cells for well
with the b27 plus catalog on the left
would be 27 plus in the middle and the
supplier BP
right and within this activity map the
first thing that's striking is the
greater coverage overall with the b27
plus we're getting 15 or 16 out of 16
electrodes in every well within that
condition and then often much less and
at lower spiking intensity in the b27
and supplier BP wells we can look at
this information from a different
perspective and that's how the the
spiking activity is organized across
space and time zone while using the
raster plot that we discussed earlier
the raster plot on the top for the b27
supplement and neuronal media the
catalog product you'll notice that
there's coverage on about half of the
electrodes a significant amount of
spontaneous firing across select few
neurons within the well and only very
rarely are there spontaneous and network
events indicated by the orange boxes and
with the four across the sixty second
recording they're happening very
infrequently and was much lower
intensity then by comparison the b27
plus a neuronal culture system which is
shown in the middle where we're getting
very regular extremely high intensity
Network bursting events and these again
are shown by the orange boxes outlining
the raster pots demarcated in the
beginning and end of each burst as well
as the histogram that's shown on top of
the raster plot finally the supplier BP
raster plot at the bottom shows that it
had and a phenotype somewhere in between
the b27 catalog and the b27 plus
neuronal culture system with the
supplier BP raster plot showing a mix of
spontaneous activity small but
relatively frequent Network events
Network spiking events and then even a
brief transition as a D synchronized
activity towards the end of the
recording raster plot over on the right
if we animate the activity map we can
actually see what this looks like in
real time so with each burst of color in
that center column indicating one of
these extremely large purse on the b27
neuronal culture
twenty-seven plus neuronal culture
system the activity on the left and
right by comparison are showing small
relatively infrequent Network events so
if we begin to quantify this using axis
navigator in the normal metric tool I'll
go through three metrics that represent
some of the key features that we
discussed earlier regarding
functionality excitability and
connectivity the first is the active
electrode coverage for the number of
electrodes in a weld that are covered by
a cell and this is critically important
because a reliable assessment of the
network electrophysiology requires
measurements from many neurons within a
network to do to calculate this
information we defined a minimum
threshold of spiking activity where
above that mean firing an electrode was
determined an active electrode so out of
16 electrodes for well we find that the
active electrodes for b27 plus wells
achieved near-perfect coverage
shortly after functional activity
emerged so with activity emerging around
day 7 and 10 in vitro and the full
coverage across over 15 active
electrodes per well was achieved by the
B 27 plus by day 15 in culture by
comparison with a b27 catalog product
took much longer to reach full coverage
around a 19 and then dropped
precipitously after that this a lot
supplier BP wells
she was similarly early rise in active
electrode coverage but then decreased
over time and had ultimately settled
around 10 to 10 to 12 active electrodes
per well so the B 27 plus system shown
in orange exhibited the greatest
electrode coverage of all media tested
with coverage stable across many days in
culture the next that I'd like to focus
on is excitability or functionality and
this is measured by the mean firing rate
of the cells and so in this case this
this is defined by the total number of
action potentials detected per second so
the mean
and what we found was that neural
activity steadily increased for networks
culture than b27 plus before stabilizing
at approximately 30 days in vitro and we
look at the plot over on the right
quantitatively you can see that you
achieved about three times as much
activity insofar as mean fine grain for
the b27 plus wells as compared to the
b27 catalog or the supplier BP and again
important to note as we'll discuss a
little bit further on that fairly stable
mean firing rate between days 26 to day
35 certain sum right here the b27 plus
system and orange promoted a higher
degree of firing activity as a network
matured and as quantified via the mean
finally finally synchronized network
activity which is arises from strong and
numerous synaptic connections between
neurons within a mature network was
quantified using the synchrony index and
this was a metric that's computed
automatically in the neural metric tool
and was modified from Paiva at all 2010
so what we show here in the plot on the
right is that this network at maturation
as measured by the synchrony index peaks
and then stabilizes around 8:15 in
culture very shortly after functional
activity emerges again this is in
comparison with b27 catalog product
which shows relatively low values for
synchrony index consistent with the D
synchronized activity we observed in the
raster plot earlier on in the salon
presentation and then the supplier BP
Wells which shared an initial increase
in synchrony but then as the activity
matured and the network matured over
time approached intermediate value of
synchrony index that's the b27 plus
system shown an orange facilitated
stronger network development as
evidenced by the high degree of
synchrony relative to other media
systems to summarize this first portion
of the talk particularly around the
maturation of rodent cortical activity
in the B 27 plus
the b27 plus culture system supported
high active electrode coverage such as
the required cell density may be reduced
for more more cost efficient assay so as
I mentioned before these studies were
performed at two different cell
densities and the Selden's Enid 80,000
cells per well performed exceptionally
well to be 27 plus culture system
suggesting that potentially fewer cells
could be used for well an implementation
of a rodent cortical neuron assay the
other thing that's important to
highlight about the high active electric
coverage is the feasibility of moving
this assay to a 96-well plate which in
the 1960 well plates from hak-seon have
eight electrodes per well and such that
if a perfect active electrode coverage
is being achieved as was observed here
with the between seven plus culture
system and we'd guarantee or have eight
electrodes for well which would be
sufficient for performing various
neurophysiological assays second the
electrophysiological phenotype is
characterized by high punk spontaneous
firing rates and strong synchrony
suggesting mature synaptic connections
are made throughout the functional
network consistent with a lot of the
structural work and that had structural
results that have been demonstrated by
thermo Fisher coverage excitability and
connectivity were stable over at large
asset window as well with coverage and
connectivity peaking around a 15 in
vitro and being fairly stable from day
15 to day 35 whereas the mean firing
rank and reach stability around a 26 to
date set at 35 again providing
significant experimental flexibility
after network maturity has reached in
the second half of the study I'm going
to go over some pharmacological results
and so this is using these same plates
so recall we had 80,000 cells per well
across four media conditions b27 catalog
b27 plus b27 with serum and the supplier
BP media formulation we then dosed with
carbamazepine TMS
and Peter Thompson across the plate as
indicated in the plate map in the upper
right such that we got two replicates
per compound per condition per plate
across each of the three plates a
sequential dosing scheme was used for
each plate with five concentrations for
each treatment condition the DMSO at
point 1 percent was used for compound
preparation and less served as the
vehicle control a 30-minute recording
was collected for baseline activity and
after each sequential dose and the last
10 minutes of each recording was used to
compute network activity in points this
is illustrated in the bottom right
corner of the slide where again with the
sequential dose increasing
concentrations the compounds were added
to the same walls over time so the
network activity phenotype was tracked
across concentrations of a particular
compound for the same well and this was
repeated for five sequential doses here
I'm showing across this slide a series
of raster plots across that sequential
disk so the top raster plot indicates
the baseline conditions - prior to
dosing and then each of the subsequent
raster plot shows an increasing
concentration the vehicle controls in
this case the MSO used at point 1
percent for vehicle control and then
subsequently with each addition for the
sequential dose up to 0.5% the MSM near
qualitatively on the Left will note that
the bursting activity is unaffected
so I've roughly quantified the bursts
for 300 seconds which is shown here on
the right of the raster plot where there
is 9 9 10 7 8 and 9 Network bursts per
300 seconds this is a very rough
quantification and then actually we can
see in the plot in the lower right the
network bursts frequency percent change
relative to baseline across the five
doses showing the very little effect for
the DMSO vehicle controlled wells and
this is consistent what we observed
qualitatively also if you pay attention
to the raster plot on the left you'll
know
that the shape and size of the burst
does not change across the addition of
the vehicle control and with the shape
and size of the burst remaining
unchanged and the network first
frequency remaining unchanged by virtue
of that the mean firing rate is also
unchanged which is also shown in the top
right portion of the plot so in summary
the network phenotype was robust
displaying little change in response to
addition of the vehicle control on this
slide we're showing the results from
Pico toxin which is a pro convulsant
reference compound often used for
characterization of protein Vulcan and
effects in vitro with a similar format
were shown in the raster plot for the
baseline and then the raster plot for
increasing concentrations of Pico toxin
as you move down the slide in this case
I've changed it scales we're looking at
a raster plot of a hundred seconds of
activity and quantifying the bursts per
100 seconds just to the right of the
raster plot and immediately you'll
notice that even at the lowest count
concentration of pinker toxin 10 nano
molar we're showing a significant
increase in network burst frequency
going from five bursts per 100 seconds
to 15 verse per 100 seconds this
continues to increase with increasing
concentrations of Pico toxin until
saturating at around 35 bursts for 100
seconds in the pker toxin at 100 micro
molar concentration this is quantified
across wells and the plot on the lower
right portion of the slide where the
network bursts frequency again shows a
dose-dependent
increase in the frequency and response
to Kerr toxin again similar with the
previous slide the actual morphology of
the bursts did not change significantly
as far as the birth duration or a number
of spikes per burst and access the
network burst frequency was reflected by
a change in the mean firing so in
summary on this slide pker toxin
increased Network burst frequency and
res Mississippi which among other
metrics indicates Pro convulsant risk
finally carbamazepine which is an anti
epileptic drug that's been on the market
for many years decreased and eliminated
the network phenotype so using the same
slide format
before we have the baseline raster plot
at the top with increasing
concentrations of carbamazepine going
down the slide again in this case we're
zoomed out to where the raster plot
represents 300 seconds of activity with
quantified of 10 10 10 5 2 and 0 Network
bursts per 300 seconds such that even at
concentrations as low as 10 micromolar
of carbamazepine we're seeing a
significant change in the network burst
frequency by dropping from 10 to 5
moving some concentrations through
micromolar to 10 micromolar
beyond just changes in network burst
frequency we saw changes in Network
burst organization as well and that's
shown in the top right and the burst
irregularity this is a measure of how
rhythmic the vs. are occurring in time
which in baseline are occurring roughly
every 30 seconds with very little jitter
in that inner burst interval whereas as
you add more and more commands appear
starting to observe this at the third
concentration 10 micromolar you get a
significant variability in that
interbirth interval which when
quantified as burst irregularity should
a significant change in those three in
those four and then ultimately a
decrease in those 5 due to the
elimination of Network bursting and the
maturity of wells consistent with this
elimination of Network bursting we
quantified the percentage of spikes that
occurred within Network burst and then
percentage change from baseline through
the dose conditions for carbamazepine we
saw a significant reduction in the
number of Network bursts at 10
micromolar carbamazepine while the
spontaneous activity between the bursts
was larger tained
and this ultimately leads to a reduction
in the percentage of spikes in network
burst while the means Brian rate doesn't
change significantly
so in summary here carbamazepine
decreased Network burst frequency and
mean firing rate overall consistent with
results from other anti epileptic drugs
in summary here for the pharmacology
results in general the network activity
phenotype responded with
and expected trends for carbamazepine
and anti-epileptics drug and pker toxin
unknown pro convulsant reference
compound the responses to each compound
also deviated from the vehicle control
response which was stable relative to
the baseline activity influence related
to functionality excitability and
connectivity were all sensitive to the
known reference compounds in summary for
the talk micro electrode array assays
provide a functional measure of
networked electrophysiology for
applications and drug discovery safety
and toxicology in disease in addition
modeling key aspects of acetate
sensitivity and reproducibility are
determined throughout network maturation
which is influenced significantly by the
culture system during development the
b27 plus network phenotype produced the
highest electrode coverage highest mewn
firing rate and the highest network
synchrony as compared to other commonly
used commercial culture systems the b27
plus network phenotype was sensitive to
perturbations with an antiepileptic and
pro convulsant reference compounds and
with that I'd like to acknowledge from
the team members and accion and thermo
Fisher that were critical to the work in
particular at Anthony Nicolini and
Collin heroin who have performed the
majority of the experiments Heather
Haines for assistants and data analysis
and my Clement and Jim Ross for their
direction additionally at Thermo Fisher
Scientific Michael der hunter tuck
melissa stewart and david cunning ER the
special reference to Michael Dirr who
helped with implementation and analysis
and interpretation of the data thank you
and I'd like to open it to any questions
the presentation we will now start the
live Q&A portion of the webinar if you
have any questions you'd like to ask
please do so now just click on the green
Q&A button at the lower left of your
presentation window type your questions
into the box that appear on the screen
and click the send button well answer as
many questions as we have time for I'd
also like to draw your attention to a
link pops up on the screen now here you
can learn more about maestro pro and
maestro edge that might not be answered
during the Q&A so let's take a look at
our questions from our audience members
now and welcome audience again to this
live Q&A portion our first question for
you doctor is which measure of the
neural network phenotype is most useful
across application areas that's that's a
great question
I'll start I guess in a couple of
different aspects first is that there
are multiple portions of the network
phenotype that provide very specific
information that the three of us that we
focused on during the talk were
functionality excitability and
connectivity so for instance just the
mere fact that the neurons are active
and the action potential are being
detected by the electrode provide some
information on the functionality where
those neurons are actually functionally
active and then finally synchrony
provides of course some input as to
whether the cells are networked together
so that when one action potential is
transmitted from one neuron to another
that that second neuron is activated
within the network now beyond the
metrics providing very specific
information about certain aspects of the
culture and the maturation we found that
for much of our internal work aspects of
the network bursting or synchrony and
phenotype are the most predictive and
that's generally for compound dosing and
compound evaluation in particular
network birth duration or Network burst
frequency are extremely sensitive to the
interplay of excitation and inhibition
within the
work such that if a compound perturbs
that balance and shifts it to one end or
the other there's very clear and readily
understood changes in the network birth
duration either getting longer or
shorter or vice versa the network versus
frequency becoming higher or lower that
makes sense from mechanistic
understanding of how that should work
with a excitation inhibition last thing
I'll mention there is that the multiple
parameters of the network phenotype are
particularly useful in other areas of
disease in addition modeling we're
trying to recreate a disease phenotype
in a dish and such that when that
genetic mutation or other introduction
of the disease phenotype is made there
are a number of different aspects of the
phenotype that can be used to
characterize and determine a fingerprint
if you will of how that disease
phenotype manifests for a particular
network thank you and nothing more
was there any media changes that
occurred during the culture period for
be 27 and B 27 plus + supplier BP and if
so how often
yes the media changes were done on a
Monday Wednesday Friday schedule so 3
media changes per week with no weekend
work involved and cultures were carried
out in those 3 media conditions
throughout the entirety of cultural
maturation so b27 catalog wells received
only be 27 throughout the duration of
the study and vice-versa for the be 27
plus and supplier BP thank you our next
question is does be 27 + need to be used
during the entire maturation period to
achieve the neural network phenotype
described in your presentation that's a
good follow-up question - the last
question and that you I guess another
way of asking the question would have
been what would have happened if we had
switched from b27 catalog to be 27 + at
day 21 in vitro and we have to form some
very preliminary expiry
in this regard and the answer is that be
27 plus is needed during the entire
maturation period and this and I think
intuitively this makes sense that the
network maturation is a dynamic process
that have occurs over a long period of
time in culture and it's very dependent
on the activity and health of the cells
during that time and so if once that
maturation and synaptic connections once
those have been formed that there's
little that you can kind of undo
aside from simply changing the ionic
balances in the media so again that with
very preliminary results the answer is
yes you need to be 27 plus throughout
the duration of the experiment
thank you dr. Martin thank you to our
audience members we have some excellent
questions coming in our next question
your data showed cells in be 27 plus
having more activities than the other
two media but which one was closer to
activities in vivo
I'm sorry cloud means can be true well
I'm guessing that in vivo and it's an
interesting question so these were
rodent cortical neurons and so actually
my background previously in graduate
school was with in vivo recordings and
cortical employment neurons and cortical
neurons in a rodent and a WIC baby
behaving rodent are approximately ten
Hertz so what we saw with the b27 plus
media which I'll switch over to now was
about 10 Hertz firing rate across the
network and so I think as far as what is
most consistent with in vivo as far as
just general excitability
I think the b27 plus is most similar
thank you and how did the environmental
control variables like temperature and
co2 affect the neural network phenotype
excuse me and yes the environmental
controls with neurons can be very
important in particular temperature and
so increases in temperature generally
lead
and this is across our experience with
multiple cell types and Multan multiple
media types generally leads to faster
and shorter network burst events whereas
decreased temperature has the opposite
effect so longer bursts and much less
frequent bursts these temperature
changes or responses to changes in
response to temperature and take about
five minutes to settle unstable at
stabilize out whereas it can take longer
to re-equilibrate to proper pH via co2
equilibrate so that's longer on the
15-minute time frame thank you very much
and here's our next question
is stimulation available on the maestro
Pro and maestro edge and if so how does
this enhance in vitro neural acid yeah
so stimulation is definitely available
on the maestro prone edge in a couple of
different formats the first via
electrical stimulation from any one of
the 768 electrodes on a plate actually
NMU plate and that's in any combination
across this electrode so each electrode
has its own independent stimulator and
then also separately with optogenetics
via the Lumos which is a multi well
optogenetic stimulator that interfaces
directly with maestro probes and so as
far as how can stimulation enhance the
assay I think there's a really three key
areas in my opinion the first is
reliability and sensitivity of the assay
so by stimulating each well you can
control the firing of each well such
there the network burst events are
happening at the same frequency and
that's going to help to reduce
wall-to-wall variability and allow you
to focus on other variables or
parameters such as the network burst
duration when the network verse
frequency is held constant the second is
access to additional endpoints with
metrics of revoked activity and so
there's additional metrics that can be
computed in response to
a stimulation event that would
complement some of the metrics that we
talked about in the webinar today
and then finally is the idea of a
targeted a-sayin whereby you might have
a specific mechanism of interest that
due to a disease phenotype or a compound
that you're evaluating and it's possible
to design stimulation protocols that
specifically target that mechanism
whether it's a mechanism related to
adaptation or frequency specific ion
channel blah
thank you so much dr. Miller our next
question does having a higher mean fire
rate in higher synchrony synchrony have
advantages for interpreting compound
treatment conditions
yeah it's that's a that's another good
question so for interpreting compounds
treatment conditions I would say the
first and foremost is that you want to
have reliable activity across wells and
in particular reliable response to the
DMSO and so quickly jump over to our
DMSO slide here just have it in the
background while I'm talking but to have
a very stable response the vehicle
control that's used to deliver compounds
is really important in able to be able
to resolve any differences or changes
that might occur with compound addition
and as far as having a good degree of
synchrony it's important to have
synchrony such that then if you're
adding a compound that is going to
affect or reduce that synchrony you'd be
able to detect that or resolve that
difference thank you dr. miller and how
different ECM coatings and ECM embedding
affect the fire firing frequency oh did
you get that okay yeah so that it's
interesting if if I'm interpreting the
question correctly we typically use in
this case we used poly B lysine as far
as a a coating on the plates in order to
help encourage the cells to attach and
grow and then we've also used in the
past
Pei to a facilitate detachment of the
neurons and really what we found is that
the attachment is is critical to keep
the neurons in place and keep them from
clumping
but once the neurons are there their
activity is not significantly affected
and if if the question is about
something more detailed as far as actual
extracellular matrix proteins please
feel free to reach out to me via email
and I'd be happy to try and answer the
question
in more detail with a little bit more
information
thank you dr. Hardin thank you again
audience members here's our next
question what's the difference between
be 27 and be 27 plus and it's a two-part
question is there anything added to the
B 27 plus that improves its activity
yeah so I am unfortunately probably not
the most qualified person to answer
exactly what is different between the
actual components within be 27 and B 27
plus I'd encourage you to reach out to
representatives at thermo Fisher and in
fact if you reach out to me I'd be happy
to put you in contact with them my
understanding of the B 27 plus is that
it is an optimized formulation of B 27
so it's many of the same components and
really it was an optimized formulation
with no added small molecules or growth
factors thank you we have time for one
more question is standard error or
standard deviation shown on the graph
yes good question
the graphs all used standard error for
the error bars and throughout the
presentation and that was that varying
number of replicates I think was
described throughout the presentation
but early on in the study and/or the
presentation where I'm showing
maturation metrics that's across CIN 6
replicates per plate per condition but
then towards the end with the dosing
results there's many fewer replicates as
we use those same six replicates for
plate and split across three compounds
dr. Muller for your presentation and
thank you audience members for your live
participation dr. Miller did you want to
provide the audience with any closing
remarks no thank you all for your
attention and participation in the
question and answer and it really was a
pleasure to share some of the results
that we were able to achieve with the B
27 plus media using the maestro pro
system encourage you to reach out to me
via email my email address is included
in an elaborate profile or reach out to
us through the acción Biosystems website
if you have any additional questions
thank you again for joining us today dr.
Millard and I'd also like to think lab
roots and our sponsor a thermo Fisher
Scientific for making today's
educational webcast possible before we
go I want to remind everyone that
today's webcast will be available
on-demand viewing through May 2018
you'll receive an email from Roberts
letting you know when this webcast will
be available for replay please share the
announcement with your colleagues who
may have missed today's live event
that's all for now and thanks for
joining us we hope to see you again soon
bye bye